foreign
[Music]
thank you
so this is part three of Gateway Aikido
video 15.
so let's take a step back
we we reviewed
tactically where does aikido's nagawasa
fall what's the Tactical opening for it
okay
that was pretty much part one in part
two we continued on that theme
but we really brought it into also the
importance of ikey at the contact Point
okay the adhesion now we're going to
take a step back because the whole point
of video 15
is uh on the topic of addressing
aikido's traditional strikes in giwaza
okay so
nagawaza two aikido's traditional
strikes
[Music]
why do you do it what are you trying to
do okay
so there's a couple of things to think
of
um
one is a Buddhist model but again
remember when you're talking about Silk
Road cultures they don't draw these
clear distinctions between these schools
of thoughts the way a western academic
would
um or a contemporary Western martial
artist or even a westernized East Asian
which is the majority
of
East Asian martial artists now training
westerners they've been westernized okay
you don't have this clear cut between
Buddhism and taoism that ism is the
problem
okay but it does help us in a certain
way
because we can think of the larger
school of thought to make sure we're not
going adrift on how to understand the
concept that we are looking at okay
so the Buddhist concept that we're
looking at is
shoe ha
d
this is related to giwasa okay
um
the best way of defining this so that so
that it works for you as a
a utilitarian understanding meaning that
you could actually gain something from
it in your practice and it's not just
jargon that academic talks about okay so
this is the problem the Buddhist
problematizing
of the egoic mind and the Buddha nature
or the Buddha mind okay
so this
for us roll call form is the world of
form
and then we'll have this one we'll call
non-form
and then this one
is the reconciliation
of form and non-form
foreign
the day in westerners and westernized
East Asians to see this as a kind of
progression training
so first learn form
I don't know how you would learn
non-form okay
but usually they'll say break the form
it's because the literal translation
would be break the form hold the form
break the form okay but if you're
intentionally breaking the form you're
only learning more forms so this is a
misunderstanding of Buddhist
um
philosophy Buddhist psychology Buddhist
ontology Buddhist soteriology that's why
it does help to if you understand the
ism part the larger understanding at
work you would never go first learn form
then break the form that would only be
more form okay
this is this is just more Buddhist mind
understanding so your egoic mind is
going to work with form
you need to have your God mind using our
discourse is working with non-form
you can't just work in the god mind
so what your ultimate aim is a
Reconciliation of form and non-form
meaning
they become
non-antagonistic to each other
you see
to the point that they become
indistinguishable to both the person
doing it and most particularly from that
person so as you're doing it as Naga
even if you were to do equal
subjectively
you're doing it from here you don't feel
ego you're not doing Iko okay a third
person watch you might look and go that
looks like
but you will also see
techniques never ever done before and
never ever done again
and they will appear as natural
as if it was a technique a form you've
been studying for decades okay
you also tend not to know what you did
because you're not operating at this
level in a a pseudo break the form do
you see that from this point of view
you're more in the flow if we were to
adopt modern terminology which means
you're not working with your intellect
right or what we would call the egoic
mind because it's more than your
intellect you're not functioning through
your fear you're not functioning through
your desires you're not functioning
through your repulsions do you see that
or your avoidance there's a there's this
a pure acceptance so everything looks
smooth
you see everything is smooth There's no
distinction okay there's no interruption
there's no staccato uh uh attributes to
the movement you see there's no
reversing there's no hesitation because
form does not exist
got it
this
is related to a phrase that osensei did
uh utilized okay and this is taka musu
I key
okay so we know what i t is it's the
reconciliation of Yin and Yang okay so
the distinction ceases to exist you see
this takamusu means under spontaneous
conditions
okay so when you do giwasa
you could use either model
or when I do giwasa
I'm going to reconcile form a non-form
but because you're an aikidoka
as you reconcile form a non-form
energetically you have yin and younger
reconciled and Ike manifest itself okay
the I.T
is going to manifest itself in such a
way that you are always under control of
the UK
which also allows you to reconcile form
a non-form
because the uke can never do anything
wrong
there's nothing in the ukia's movements
that causes you to be repulsed by it
afraid of it or
Desiring them to do something else
so there's no need to pick a technique
what is happening is per is happening
perfectly
do you understand okay
what's important to note is
you can look at this
in our three components of training
these two things
we have our spiritual component where we
have the two minds
this Buddhist model
is
operating at the spiritual component
this is the energetic component
but you know
you can't reconcile yin and Yong energy
without reconciling the two minds you
see
so when you put this into
giwasa
and it's a matter of Marshall
application so to speak
it's also your physical component okay
so these things are happening
simultaneously and this training is the
point
of viewers
is not sparring
is not trying to do Aikido nagiwasa on
someone
in fact you're more accurate to say
as I said giwas is not as far because G
was us not about fighting because
fighting requires opposition attacker
Defender do you see but it's all it's
not it's not it's not also aikido's
version of sparring you see
it's a technology of self of this nature
likewise it's not trying to do Aikido
nagewaza because that's this stuck on
this do you see it's in a way is trying
to transcend form
is trying to transcend the opposition
between form and non-form okay
so hence it would be a problem
to just keep doing kihon haza
to pick kihonawaza to do to try to do
kilon was that to try to force uke into
this kihon Maza or that as much as it
would be a problem that nowhere in what
you did
did we see a technique that's never done
before and never done again
just because of the mathematical
probability you see if you're if you are
reconciling form and non-form if you're
doing it long enough we should see a
technique you've never done before
okay this just the way it works out okay
got it
all right
let's get to this okay
so because that is what I'm working on
in my opinion
it's not really important that you
try to do all of
aikido's curriculum if that would be a
problem likewise it's not important that
you have to do jiwasa for strikes who
cares this this is that kind of
orientation
this is a spiritual energetic practice
not sparring
if you're concerned because you had a
professional and was Marshall
you're going to have to do way more than
G wasm you're going to have this far got
it okay so with that in mind I tend not
to do
the strikes when I do GUI
I either say come in with whatever
or we've just worked with graphs Okay
the reason we prioritize grams for you
all here is it requires less of this
already being having been cultivated in
you okay they operate a little slower
there's a kinesthetic index Point not
just a spiritual uh connection you don't
even need it because it's physically
touching you you
um
but still it presents its own problems
right
right okay so go to the basics and
that's why we're gonna do part three is
return to the basics what is guasa what
am I working on okay well why did we say
part one and part two do not stop
looking
do not stop UK
do not Clash or video at any point
and uh get an IDE adhesion
okay so as I go we're just doing
katatore right
go back
I'm not going to sit here and wait for
him
we're already moving I'm not going to
walk at him
I'm going to start my spiral going do
you get it so he's coming in I move at
his intention if you can see that that I
already started it I'm not here
nor am I going right in there
and his intention
I'm already spiraling you see I'm not
gonna slam him there
boom a very big contact here's the yield
you see the yield so a lot you were
trying some variant of that so
we're not going to stop we're not going
to clash a hand here you go when you
want I move at his attention do you see
you came here and you're trying to do
this thing you got into the heel because
now you're stopping them go back rewind
the film he's coming around
boom there it is right there
if you'll come in here that's good
that's good figure out
where that is
thank you
down to the adhesion do you feel it you
feel it
[Music]
I'm not gonna go like this
you're in his body so pull pull
do you feel it keep pulling so he's not
pushing on me he's not pushing on me
foreign
[Music]
you can move him
so feel for it
[Music]
find the relationship
the IC energetic relationship
concerned
no he doesn't want to go down
so don't reach feel you should feel he
doesn't want to go down here
Sudoku you will go down
you already feel his lifting
so you use the lifting
got it
okay
try again
[Music]
keep going
do you kill yourself
leave you for help okay
did you did you feel her fur here okay
how does it manifest do you know how you
manifested in geological you saw okay is
that how what you felt when she mad she
stopped okay
now
stopping is just an energy
it's not stopping
okay going if you have going and
stopping you're in the ego of life
stopping should not exist
Okay so
she stopped
and you went ego with mine you went
dichotomous response you see you went
will the power over her your turn Okay
so
even her fear
you see her fear is also dichotomous you
cannot be reactionary to her fear okay
so you're gonna experience this
and I'll ask you try to be sensitive to
what you're feeling so right now you're
nervous as hell do you see that okay uh
watch what happens to the nervousness
okay now we come in
good
foreign
field
okay
that's not sorry that was fine
thank you
[Music]
you feel this here yes okay
watch it again
did you seize up okay but watch compare
oh you see
watching yourself again
there's the Seas you see so you have the
back rainfall
but you're like no no that's scary
and then you come in and twist these
energy is right there here's the next
opening
you see then you push in you push up you
see
she pushes up goes this way now
then you put post it's that's fine this
is fear
and it's over here
okay
this is and inhale and the Gasping watch
yourself
there it is
cool
it just sees up
no you didn't not like the other time
can you tell the difference okay and do
it again
see your body doesn't like that back
face all right
foreign
in other words it's just more energy
you get it I don't force her there's her
counter
here's the counter right there she
doesn't want the shoulder going down
it's fine do you
so you're going to turn that way do you
see but I'm going to go this way
there it is
good there's the counter
there's the counter take this one
so instead of uh
think about it
what is the counter the counter only
exists because I was trying something
if I didn't have something to try
that energy in the counter is not any
different from that energy there
you understand
and I didn't I didn't go
she push it I'll let her push it explode
there's the counter do you think
that's my opportunity to train
and how many throws do you think you've
done
how many would you say
no no then I started throwing her Aziz
yes
how many reps did she have asuke
20 30 40. what do you think
don't worry
oh
again
come on
[Music]
good
Ness
that's four keep going let's do eight
three more
foreign
[Music]
okay
so that was eight
hey
come on so that was eight look at again
someone describing I don't think she's
you don't sense yourself too well
give me one characteristic as a trained
Observer what do you see
she's breathing a lot
anxious
jittery again can you name some things
how you feel
it okay
again found it I'm gonna say it's
somewhere around 20 at a minimum
did you did she look like that at 20. no
do you get it why
you were not
he's not going fast by the way okay
why
it's so different it was different can
you sing there was two times when I made
it like that what were those two times
yeah the non-examples the choke and
shoving you down okay got if had I done
eight of those you'd look exactly like
this
so
this is this is the cosmic principle of
things
okay
fear is a Darkness
do you see it it's its mission is to
spread
to to overwhelm
to cover
10 golf
and in a way it's like you can think of
it as a virus
a disease you see
that is that mission
and so when you feel her
then it goes into you
and then it amplifies in you
see
remember
at the heart of what we're doing is a
Reconciliation of fear
so when we have
and let's look at a couple things
there's plenty of those in those eight
reps where you have like total perfect
balance
did you pay did you guys see all that
go back to the 20 reps
do you see anything
you're moving
you're not I'm not on your line of
attack
do you get it you're gonna fall anyways
you're gonna resist you see but I don't
get taken by the darkness and I don't
feed your Darkness
scene
and then the light
the eye King right which is not fear
which is a love Embrace that's that's
what I was trying to get you to notice
but you you know what you you could not
notice
that it was infecting you
because you kept anticipating that was
gonna happen
do you see
so you wouldn't let yourself be
conscious of how many reps you were
actually taking
do you get it so we I filmed you earlier
and the same thing you did four reps you
absolutely spent okay
right we know we know we know you okay
from a certain point of view there's no
way you could take 20 throws in a row
even at that pace but here you did
you get it
but even at some point as the life as
the love the light is pushing the
darkness away the love is replacing the
fear at some point you have to let go
do you see you have to stop identifying
with the Darkness at some point
okay you cannot keep going
and staying like that
because even when the light and the love
is in you and you're able to do things
you normally couldn't do you in that
moment you would have never said
I don't feel winded I don't you kept
coming back in with the
the fear look do you see do you get it
and nothing that was even happening okay
you got you got that okay
we needed to go back to the contrast and
everyone go look you're not seeing
what's obvious
you missed what was obvious before
okay
so back to my other dishy here
you have to think of this cosmically
you have to understand if you're doing
geology you have to understand
there's nothing wrong with their
movement
movement is movement energy is energy
it's only wrong or it only stops it'll
or it only needs to change when I am
stuck on form
when the egoic mind is functioning do
you see otherwise it's more like a dance
do you see that we're kind of just
dancing
right okay
um and in a way
when you have somebody
[Music]
that is so used to the darkness it
happens you see that's how the whole
world is function
the whole world does not recognize the
darkness okay because we assimilate to
it
we acclimate so to speak and then we use
the world's tonics so that we don't die
right away or go crazy right away just
slowly over time
but as you're as you're as you're
training in this okay
you have to think of it cosmically oh a
battle a spiritual battle
I will not be taken by that fear
do you see because that's what you do
have to do daily daily you have to do
that the darkness is trying to take you
and daily you have to go I will not be
taken by the darkness so here it is in
the microcosm of geoaza your UK is
terrified
do not be taken by them you can unparify
them do you think
then you become an imager of God
you you could train in a much more
pleasant manner
because that other one
was probably less than five minutes of
training now
do that for an hour no way Christine
okay
so every time you have that because
everyone's gonna come people are going
to come in like that
because they're coming from the world
we're like that
but if you're trying to do GE Wasa
you have you if you and you understand G
was that correctly
this is a cosmic battle between Darkness
and Light and who succumbs to what
and you recognize in you
when it spread to you I'm gonna I'm
gonna young young you this isn't righty
Cami this isn't good there's no such
thing in G was it was a yes but not in G
was it everything that's happening is
just perfectly fine
okay so as you're training you will feel
you will you have to become sensitive to
it you will feel the darkness you will
feel the demon bite on you and you have
to do your releasing skill see but you
cannot confuse releasing
with disengaging I felt I felt you in
this last one where you did the a you
could tell when she got resistant and
then
you did not force it you see but you
disengaged
you're I do not disengage the I.T
adhesion just moves to the next location
do you see do you get that okay and
that's the difference okay because
disengaging in the face of the darkness
is still the darkness
it is still the darkness okay
it's the ultimate trick of the darkness
foreign